Hey David, how do we move the Republican party
to the left?
It's a good question and there are basically
two answers.
Number one is we moved the Republican party
to the left by moving the democratic parties
that at off.
The second answer is we move the Republican
party to the left by working at the local
level like Republicans are so good at doing
to get left wingers elected to school boards
and city councils and PTA, you know, whatever
at the local level because this is how Republicans
have successfully won thousands of seats.
If you consider down to the local level, tens
of thousands of seats even, excuse me, over
the last several years, several decades actually.
Number one, if we can move the Overton window
to the left of national political discussions,
the Republican party is going to have to come
left at least on some issues.
A lot of them have on the issue of gay marriage,
for example.
It feels like so long ago, but it wasn't that
long ago that the Supreme court decision in
June of 2015 said you can't ban same sex marriage
at the state level and not all, there's still
a lot of money raised in evangelical circles
around being anti-gay, but a lot of Republicans
have just sort of forgotten about it and they're
now at least centrists on the issue of gay
marriage.
It's just one example.
As we continue to move the conversation to
the left on health care, the catalyst for
which was Bernie Sanders back in 2016 inserting
this issue, uh, in a serious way into the
public discussion overall, you are pulling
Republicans to the left as well.
Now they still want free market, blah, blah,
blah, all of that stuff.
But more of them are willing to make some
concessions about either preexisting conditions
or whatever else.
So the point is if the democratic party moves
to the left, it will force because we know
that the public is moving left as well.
It will force the Republican party to come
somewhat to the left.
And then we've got to work at the local level.
I know that it's, it sounds so boring.
It sounds almost cliche.
Uh, it sounds almost axiomatic to say Democrats
have to be working at the local level, but
Democrats just don't do it.
Well, the Democrats don't do it well.
That's the reality and what happens is there's
a sort of two fold effect, number one by working
really well at the local level, everything
from school boards to city councils, to mayor,
ships of smaller towns and cities, all that
stuff.
Uh, what Republicans do is they make it so
that they aren't in a position to have to
make things happen at the state or federal
level as quickly because they have all these
people already doing it when it comes to curricula
in schools because they've got the school
boards, all of these other things.
If we can get involved in that, we are going
to have a lot of those same successes presumably.
But also they have basically like a farm team
to use a baseball analogy.
They've got the minor leagues and they have
all sorts of people from which they can hand
pick the most charismatic and the most sort
of PR friendly and then start winning bigger
races in the house of representatives.
Some of these folks can even become senators,
et cetera.
So those are the two areas where Democrats
need to start working right away.
If we want to move the Republican party to
the left, we know the way to do it.
Move ourselves to the left as leftists, both
through the democratic party and outside of
it.
Uh, and we've got to start winning the local
races.
It's just, it's, it's truly disheartening
to see the degree to which Democrats have
failed at the local level for so many years
and in large swaths of the United States.